hi Adrian it's always so good to see you
I love talking to you you know you threw
us for a loop last season on the masked
singer yes now I'm hoping now that
that's all done you can open up I can
keep it real fun intended pun intended
um I want to start off by asking you
about something that happened earlier
this year that set the internet on fire
okay you show up to the women's March
Raven shows up to the website wait what
did I do
you gave us the Cheetah Girls reunion
that we really wanted and to see the two
of you on stage together was just like
it gives me goose bumps because it makes
me feel like we might be one step closer
to something happening so are there
conversations there are not
conversations but the cool thing is that
Raven and I have continued our
friendship throughout the years and it's
so crazy because what I loved most about
being in the Cheetah Girls was the
message of women empowerment about girl
power and like what that was and it was
crazy cuz in my mind like 15 years later
this is exactly where bubbles and Chu
Chu would have been at the women's
margins you don't I'm saying like I
literally felt like this is where our
characters would have met up and they
would have been like yes girls together
together we can you know um I think you
just wrote a screenplay right that hey
what would a dream Cheetah Girls project
in 2020 look like bubbles and Chu Chi
take on the world I think like just the
iconic friendship that we had I think
also just the fact that we're still
friends in real life and on top of that
maybe we became solo artists and come
together like years.they I don't know
I'm gonna leave the writing to someone
else okay so where does that be awesome
[Music]
so nothing is officially in the word has
not been discussed at all I just feel
like having creative forces like
yourself and Raven together how can it
not organically come up I feel like it
organically could be ruined and that
does this before that you might not
preserve it yeah cuz man I'm sorry
there's so many things that I'm a fan of
and when they redo them I'm like battle
quietly why did you feel that that was
necessary
yeah like sometimes it's just best to
bow out gracefully
surely people love it forever I'd rather
people keep wanting it to be done and
that it never gets done versus doing it
and they're like they ruined it
listen I don't think you would ever ruin
anything but I just want to put it out
there Lizzie McGuire is back with a very
mature twist really yeah she's grown up
so you know look if Lizzie McGuire can
grow up I think the Cheetah Girls can -
hey I'm gonna have to check that out
okay so we'll just and I'll get inspired
maybe yes we just want some new music I
mean whether that's what the Cheetah
Girls or you as a solo artist I mean are
you working on any new music I am I
actually just cut a [ __ ] song song
it's just like so go dirty definitely
what I really love and what I listen to
and I've always really wanted to do
something in the Latin field so we shall
see is it a collab no it's just it's
just me on my own for now okay someone
might jump on it and is it like is it up
tempo is it is it growth here it's girl
power it is okay one yeah
[Music]
you